‏to
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله استقيم اعتدل استو سو
الصف الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط الم
مستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد اتينا ابراه يم رشده من قبل
وكنا به
عالمين اذ قال لابيه وقومه ما هذه
التماثيل التي انتم لها
عاكفون قالوا وجدنا
اباء انا لها
عابدين قال لقد كنتم انتم
واباؤكم في
ضلال
مبين قالوا اجئتنا بالحق ام انت من
اللاعبين قال بل ربكم رب السماوات والارض
الذي
فطرهم وانا على
ذلكم من
الشاهدين وت الله
لاكيدن
اصنامكم بعد ان تولوا
مدبرين فجعلهم جذاذا الا كبيرا لهم لعلهم
اليه
يرجعون قالوا من ف هذا بالهتنا
قالوا من فعل هذا بالهتنا
انه لمن
الظالمين قالوا سمعنا
فت يذكرهم يقال له
ابراهيم قالوا فاتوا به على اعين الناس
لعلهم
يشهدون قالوا اانت فعلت هذا بالهتنا يا
ابراهيم قال بل فعله كبيرهم هذا
فاسالوه فاسالوه ان كانوا
ينطقون فرجعوا الى
انفسهم
فقالوا انكم انتم
الظالمون ثم نكسوا على
رؤوسهم لقد علمت ما
هؤلاء
ينطقون قال
افتعال ينف عكم شيئا ولا
يضركم اف لكم ولما تعبدون من دون
الله افلا
تعقلون قالوا حرقوه وانصروا الهتكم ان
كنتم
فاعلين قلنا يا نار كوني بردا وسلاما
على
ابراهيم وارادوا به كيدا
فجعلناهم
الاخسرين
ونجيناه ولوطا الى الارض التي باركنا فيها
للعالمين الله الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ضالين
امين
ان الذين سبقت
لهم منا
الحسنى
اولئك عنها
مبعدون لا يسمعون
حسيسها
وهم فيما اشتهت
انفسهم
خالدون لا يحزنهم الفزع
الاكبر
وتتلقاهم
الملائكه هذا يومكم الذي كنتم
توعدون يوم نطوي
السماء
كطي السجل
للكتب كما بدانا اول خلق
نعيده وعدا
علينا انا كنا
فاعلين ولقد ولقد كتبنا في الزبور من بعد
الذكر ان
الارض
ان الارض يرثها عبادي
الصالحون ان في هذا لبلاغا لقوم
عابدين
وما
ارسلناك الا رحمه
للعالمين
فان تولى قل انما يوحى الي انما الهكم
اله
واحد فهل
انتم
مسلمون فان تولوا فقل
اذنتكم على
سواء وان ادري اقريب اقريب ام بعيد
ما
توعدون
انه يعلم الجهر من القول ويعلم ما
تكتمون وان ادري لعله فتنه لكم ومتاع الى
حين قال رب احكم بالحق و ربنا الرحمن
المستعان على ما
تصفون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
الله اكبر بسم
[Silence]
الله الله اك
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
الله بس
[Silence]
‏st
استو ترا سدسد الخللا
شاء
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين والذاريات
ذرى فالحاملات
قرا فالجاريات
يسرا فالمقسمات
امرا انما توعدون لصادق وان الدين
لواقع
والسماء ذات الحبك
انكم لفي قول مختلف يؤفك عنه من افك قتل
الخراصون الذين هم في غمره
ساهون يسالون ايان يوم
الدين يوم هم على النار
يفتنون ذوقوا فتنتكم هذا الذي
كنتم به
تستعجلون
ان المتقين في
جنات
وعيون
اخذين ما اتاهم
ربهم انهم كانوا قبل ذلك
محسنين كانوا قليلا من الليل ما
يهجعون وبالاسحار هم
يستغفرون وفي اموالهم حق
للسائل
والمحروم وفي الارض ايات للموقنين
وفي
انفسكم افلا
تبصرون وفي
السماء رزقكم وما
توعدون فور
السماء والارض انه لحق
مثلما انكم
تنطقون
هل اتاك حديث ضيف ابراهيم
المكرمين اذ دخلوا عليه فقالوا
سلاما قال سلام قوم
منكرون فراغ الى اهله فجاء
بعجل
سمين
فقربه اليهم قال الا
تاكلون فاوجس منهم خيفه قالوا لا تخف
وبشروه بغلام
عليم فاقبلت امراته في
صره فصكت
وجهها فصكت وجهها وقالت عجوز
عقيم قالوا كذلك قال ربك انه هو الحكيم
العليم
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين فما خطبكم ايها
المرسلون قالوا
انا
ارسلنا الى قوم
مجرمين لنرسل عليهم
حجاره من
طين مسومه عند ربك للمسرفين
فاخرجنا من كان فيها من
المؤمنين فما وجدنا فيها غير بيت من
المسلمين وتركنا فيها ايه للذين يخافون
العذاب
الاليم وفي موسى اذ ارسلناه الى فرعون
بسلطان
مبين فتولى بركنه وقال ساحر او
مجنون فاخذناه وجنوده
فنبذناهم في اليم وهو
مليم وفي عاد اذ ارسلنا عليهم الريح
العطيم ما تذر من شيء اتت عليه الا جعلته
كالرميم
وفي ثمود اذ قيل لهم تمتعوا حتى
حين فعتوا عن امر ربهم فاخذتهم الصاعقه هم
ينظرون فما استطاعوا من قيام وما كانوا
منتصرين وقوم نوح من قبل انهم كانوا قوما
فاسقين
والسماء بنيناها بايد وانا
لموسعون والارض فرشناها فنعم الماهدون
ومن كل شيء خلقنا زوجين لعلكم
تذكرون
ففروا الى
الله اني لكم منه نذير
مبين ولا تجعلوا مع الله ال اخر اني لكم
منه نذير
مبين كذلك ما اتى الذين من قبلهم من رسول
الا قالوا الا قالوا ساحر او
مجنون اتواصوا به بل هم قوم
طاغون فتولى عنهم
فما انت
بملوم وذكر فان ان الذكرى
تنفع
المؤمنين وما خلقت الجن والانس الا
ليعبدون ما اريد منهم من رزق وما اريد ان
يطعمون ان الله هو الرزاق ذو القوه
المتين فان للذين ظلموا ذ نبا مثل ذنوب
اصحابهم فلا
يستعجلون فويل للذين
كفروا فويل للذين كفروا من يومهم الذي
يوعدون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
سجده
ركعه الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالين
الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
والنجم اذا هوى ما ضل صاحبكم وما غوى وما
ينطق عن الهوى ان هو الا وحي يوحى علمه
شديد القوى ذو
مره فاستوى وهو بالافق الاعلى ثم دنى فتد
فكان قاب قوسين او ادنى
فاوحى الى عبده ما اوحى ما كذب الفؤاد ما
راى افتمارونه على ما يرى ولقد راه نزله
اخرى عند سدره
المنتهى عندها جنه
الماوى اذ يغشى السدر ما يغشى ما زاغ
البصر وما طغى لقد راى من ايات ربه الكبرى
افرايتم اللاه والعزا ومناه الثالثه
الاخرى الكم الذكر وله
الانثى تلك اذا
قسمه
ضيزا ان هي الا
اسماء
سميتموها
سميتموها انتم
واباؤكم انتم
واباؤكم ما انزل الله بها من
سلطان ان يتبعون الا الظن وما تهوى
الانفس ولقد جاء هم من ربهم الهدى ام
للانسان ما
تمنى فلله الاخره
والاولى وكم من ملك في السماوات لا تغني
شفاعتهم شيئا لا تغني شفاعتهم شيئا الا من
بعد ان ياذن الله لمن يشاء
ويرضى ان الذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره
ليسمون
الملائكه تسميه
الانثا وما لهم به من علم ان يتبعون الا
الظن وان الظن لا يغني من الحق شيئا فاعرض
عمن تولى عن ذكرنا ولم يرد الا الحياه
الدنيا ذلك
مبلغهم من العلم ان ربك هو اعلم بمن ضل عن
سبيله وهو اعلم بمن
اهتدى ولله ما في السماوات وما في الارض
ليجزي الذين
اساءوا بما عملوا ويجزي الذين احسنوا
بالحسنى الذين يجتنبون كبا ئر الاثم
والفواحش الا اللمم ان ربك واسع المغفره
هو اعلم بكم اذ
انشاكم من الارض واذ
انتم واذ انتم
اجنه في بطون
امهاتكم فلا
تزكوا
انفسكم هو اعلم بمن
ت الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
افرايت الذي تولى واعطى
قليلا واكتى اعنده علم الغيب فهو يرى ام
لم ينبا بما في صحف موسى
وابراهيم الذي وفى الا تزر وازره وزر اخرى
وان ليس
للانسان الا ما سعى ان سعيه سوف يرى ثم
يجزاه
الجزاء
الاوفى وان الى ربك
المنتهى وانه هو اضحك
وابكى وانه هو امات واحيا وانه خلق
الزوجين الذكر
والانثى من نطفه اذا تمنا وان عليه النشاه
الاخرى وانه هو اغنى
واقنى وانه هو رب الشعرا
وانه اهلك عادا الاولى وثمود
فما ابقى وقوم نوح من قبل انهم كانوا هم
اظلم
واطغى والمؤتفكه اهوى
فغشاها ما غشى فباي
الاء ربك
تتمارى هذا نذير من النذر الاولى ازفت
الازفه ليس لها من دون الله
كاشفه افمن هذا الحديث
تعجبون
وتضحكون ولا تبكون
وانتم
سامدون فاسجدوا لله
واعبدوا الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر اقتربت الساعه وانشق القمر وان يروا
ايه يعرضوا ويقولوا سحر مستمر وكذبوا
واتبعوا
اهواءهم وكل
امر مستقر ولقد ولقد ولقد
جاءهم من
الانبا ما فيه م ازدجر
حكمه بالغه ما تغني النذر فتولى عنهم يوم
يدعى الداعي الى
شيء نكر خشعا ابصارهم يخرجون من
الاجداث يخرجون من الاجداث
كانهم
جراد
منتشر مهطعين الى
الدع يقول الكافرون هذا يوم من
عسر الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
صلى الله
عليه الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول
صلى الله عليه وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين ان شاء
الله
ديث رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم رسول
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله عليه
وسلم طبعا حديث امام احمد الترمذي ان
النسائي العربا ابن ساريه رضي الله عنه ان
ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال ضرب الله مثلا صراطا
مستقيما وعلى جانبي الصراط
سوران وفي
السورين ابواب
مفتحه
عليها ستائر
مرخاه وفي راس
الصراط داع يقول
يا ايها
الناس ادخلوا في الصراط ولا
تعوجوا فكلما وكلما حاول احد دخول باب من
هذه
الابواب اذا بواعظ اخر على على الصراط او
في
الصراط يقول
ويلك لا
تفتحه فانك ان تفتحه
تلجه ال صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله and
the
are and in two there are open gates
open
have
[Silence]
‏time
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الاسلام الله سبحانه
وتعالى اسلام
محارم
الله الله سبحانه
وتعالى
[Silence]
حرام
طبعا
الله سبحانه
وتى قران كتاب
الله هو واع الله في قلب كل مسلم
الله سبحانه
وتالى
حصلى الله عليه
وس اللهانه
وتالى
الله سبحانه
وتالى صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه وتالى الله سبحانه
وتال
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
[Silence]
وتالى
‏time الله سبحانه
وتعالى
الله سبحانه
وتالى الصراط المستقيم هو
الاسلام الله سبحانه
وتعالى سوره الفاتحه سوره
الفاتحه الله سبحانه وتاله
الفاتحه ادنا الص
المستقيم
اسلام صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
الله سبحانه
وت الله سبحانه وتعالى ومن يطع الرسول ومن
يطع الله
والرسول فاولئك مع الذين انعم الله
عليهم النبيين والصديقين والشهداء
والصالحين وحسن اولئك
رفيق
الله
[Silence]
ديقين
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏not محد صل الله عليه
وسلم الله so الله سبحانه وتعالى
س الذين اتيناهم الكتاب يعرفونه كما
يعرفون
ابناءهم محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله عبد الله بن سلام رضي الله
عنه
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله موسى عليه
السلام جريل عليه
السلام
اسلام الله سبحانه وتعالى
طبعا
any الله سبحانه
وتعالى هذا واقول قولي هذا وصلى الله وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد صلى الله عليه وعلى
اله وصحبه
[Silence]
اجمعين
استقيم
ترس
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واوحي الى نوح انه لن يؤمن من قومك
الا من قد امن فلا تبتئس بما كانوا
يفعلون واصنع الفلك باعيننا ووحينا ولا
تخاطبني في الذين ظلموا ان هم
مغرقون ويصنع الفلك وكلما مر عليه ملا من
قومه سخروا منه قال ان تسخروا منا فانا
نسخر منكم كما
تسخرون فسوف تعلمون من ياتيه
عذاب يخزيه ويحل عليه عذاب
مقيم حتى اذا
جاء امرنا وفارت النور قل نحمل فيها من كل
زوجين اثنين
واهلك قل نحمل فيها من كل زوجين اثنين
واهلك الا من سبق عليه القول ومن
امن وما امن معه الا
قليل وقال اركبوا فيها بسم الله مجريها
ومرساها ان ربي لغفور
رحيم وهي تجري بهم في موج
كالجبال
ونادى ونادى نوح ابنه وكان في معزل يا بني
اركم معنا ولا تكن مع
الكافرين قال ساوي الى جبل يعصمني من
الماء قال لا عاصم اليوم من امر الله الا
من رحم وحال بينهما الموج فكان من
المغرقين وقيل يا ارض ابلعي
ماءك ويا
سماء
اقلعي وغيض
الماء وقضي الامر واستوت على
الجودي وقيل بعدا للقوم
الظالمين ونادى نوح ربه فقال رب ان ابني
من اهلي وان وعدك الحق وانت احكم
الحاكمين قال يا نوح انه ليس من اهلك
انه عمل غير
صالح فلا تسالن ما ليس لك به علم اني اعظك
ان تكون من
الجاهلين قال رب اني اعوذ بك ان اسالك ما
ليس لي به علم والا تغفر لي وترحمني اكن
من
الخاسرين قيل يا نوح اهبط بسلام منا
وبركات عليك وعلى امم
ممن معك
وامم سنمتعهم
ثم يمسهم منا عذاب
اليم تلك من
انباء الغيب نوحيها
اليك ما كنت تعلمها انت ولا قومك من قبل
هذا فاصبر ان العاقبه
للمتقين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك ن
ستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين فاستقم كما امرت ومن تاب معك ولا تط
انه بما تعملون
بصير ولا تركنوا الى الذين ظلموا فتمسكم
النار وما لكم من دون الله من
اولياء ثم لا
تنصرون واقم الصلاه طرفي النهار وزلفا من
الليل ان الحسنات يذهبن
السيئات ذلك ذكرى
للذاكرين واصبر فان الله لا يضيع اجر
المحسنين فلولا كان من القرون من قبلكم
اولو بقيه ينهون عن الفساد في الارض الا
قليلا من من انجينا
منهم واتبع الذين ظلموا ما اترفوا فيه
وكانوا
مجرمين وما كان ربك ليهلك القرى بظلم
واهلها
مصلحون ولو
شاء ربك لجعل الناس
امه
واحده لا يزالون مختلفين الا من رحم
ربك ولذلك
خلقهم وتمت كلمه ربك
لاملان جهنم من الجنه
والناس
اجمعين وكلا نقص عليك من
انباء الرسل ما نثبت به
فؤادك
وجاءك في هذه الحق
وموعظه وذكرى
للمؤمنين وقل للذين لا يؤمنون اعملوا على
مكانتكم انا
عاملون
وانتظروا انا
منتظرون ولله غيب السماوات والارض واليه
يرجع الامر كله فاعبده وتوكل
عليه وما ربك بغافل
عما
تعملون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
واللام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
الم تر الى الذين بدلوا نعمه الله كفرا
واحلوا قومهم دار
البوار جهنم يصلونها وبئس
القرار وجعلوا لله
اندادا ليضلوا عن
سبيله قل تمتعوا ان مصيركم الى
النار قل لعبادي الذين امنوا يقيموا
الصلاه
وينفقوا مما رزقناهم سرا وع نيه من قبل ان
ياتي يوم لا بيع فيه ولا
خلال الله الذي خلق
السماوات الارض
وانزل من
السماء
ماء فاخرج به من الثمرات رزقا
لكم وسخر لكم الفلك لتجري في البحر
بامره وسخر لكم
الانهار وسخر لكم الشمس والقمر
دا بين وسخر لكم الليل
والنهار
واتاكم من كل ما
سالتموه وان تعدوا نعمه الله لا تحصوها ان
الانسان
لظلوم
كفار واذ قال ابراهيم رب اجعلها ذا البلد
امنا واجنبني وبني ان نعبد
الاصنام رب
انهن اضللن كثيرا من
الناس فمن تبعني فانه مني ومن عصاني
فانك غفور
رحيم ربنا اني
اسكنت من ذريتي بواد غير ذي زرع عند بيتك
المحرم ربنا ليقيموا
الصلاه ربنا ليقيم الصلاه فاجعل
افئده من الناس تهوي اليهم
وارزقهم من الثمرات
لعلهم
يشكرون
ربنا انك تعلم ما نخفي وما نعلن وما يخفى
على الله من شيء في الارض ولا في
السماء الحمد لله الذي وهب لي على الكبر
اسماعيل
واسحاق ان ربي لسميع
الدعاء
رب اجعلني مقيم الصلاه ومن ذريتي ربنا
وتقبل
دعاء ربنا اغفر لي
ولوالدي
وللمؤمنين يوم يقوم
الحساب الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اه ادنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولا
تحسبن الله غافلا عما يعمل
الظالمون
انما يؤخرهم
ليوم تشخص فيه
الابصار مهطعين
مقنعي رؤوسهم لا يرتد اليهم طرفهم
وافئدتهم
هوا
وانذر الناس يوم ياتيهم العذاب فيقول
الذين ظلموا ربنا اخرنا الى اجل قريب نجب
دعوتك نجب دعوتك ونتبع الرسل اولم تكونوا
اقسمتم من قبل ما لكم من
زوال
وسكنتم في مساكن الذين ظلموا
انفسهم وتبين لكم كيف فعلنا بهم وضربنا
لكم
الامثال وقد مكروا مكرهم وعند الله مكرهم
وان كان مكرهم لتزول منه
الجبال فلا
تحسبن الله مخلف وعده رسله ان الله عزيز
ذو انتق
يوم تبدل الارض غير الارض والسماوات
وبرزوا لله الواحد
القهار وترى المجرمين
يومئذ مقرنين في
الاصفاد
سرابيلهم من قطران وتغشى وجوههم النا
ليجزي الله كل نفس ما كسبت ان الله سريع
الحساب هذا بلاغ للناس ولينذروا به
وليعلموا انما هو اله
واحد وليعلموا انما هو اله واحد وليذكر
اولو
الالباب الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
صلاه الشفع الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين اذا
جاء نصر الله
والفتح ورايت الناس يدخلون في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك واستغفره انه كان
توابا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين تبت يدا ابي لهب وتب ما اغنى عنه
ماله وما كسب سيصلى نارا ذات لهب وامراته
حماله الحطب في جيدها حبل من مسد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
ستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
اجمعين اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعفو عنا
اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا اللهم
انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا اللهم انا
نسالك العفو والعافيه في الدنيا
والاخره اللهم انا نسالك العفو والعافيه
في الدنيا
والاخره اللهم احسن
خواتيمنا ووفقنا لما تحب وترضى وتوفنا
وانت راض عنا يا كريم ربنا اتنا في الدنيا
حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار ربنا لا تزغ قلوبنا بعد اذ هديتنا
وهب لنا من لدنك رحمه انك انت
الوهاب اللهم يا سامع الصوت ويا سابق
الفوت ويا محي العظام بعد الموت
اللهم امنن على اخواننا المستضعفين في غزه
والسودان بالنصر
والتمكين اللهم كن لهم عونا ونصيرا اللهم
كن لهم عونا
ونصيرا اللهم سدد رميهم وقو قلوبهم وثبت
الارض من تحت اقدامهم واحقن دماءهم اللهم
اطعمهم من جوع وامنهم من خوف اللهم لا
ينقضي هذا الشهر الكريم الا وقد حقنت
دمائهم وحفظت ابناءهم وبناتهم وشفيت
امراضهم واهلكت عدوك وعدوهم يا رب
العالمين اللهم عليك بالظالمين
والمستكبرين والمجرمين اللهم اقتلهم بددا
واحصهم واحصهم عددا ولا تذر منهم احدا
انهم يا رب لا يعجزونك
اللهم اشف امراضنا اللهم اشف امراضنا
اللهم اشف امراضنا وارحم موتانا وارحم
موتانا ووسع في
ارزاقنا ووفقنا لما تحب وترضى وبارك لنا
في ذرياتنا وازواجنا وتب علينا برحمتك
الواسعه يا اكرم الاكرمين وصلى الله وسلم
وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه ورحمت
[Silence]
الله لا اله
الا
[Silence]
ان